airlines may have overestimated
Americans desire to travel to Cuba after
the Obama administration relaxed travel
restrictions there in 2016 flights from
ten different US carriers were approved
to make trips to the island nation from
cities like Fort Lauderdale but when our
CBS crew arrived on Sunday in Havana
they found one of the last Spirit
Airlines flights about to take off
spirit is the third carrier to stop
service to Cuba because Van Cleave is in
Havana right now with why demand has
lagged expectations Chris good morning
well good morning
strict tourism to Cuba is still
prohibited so for Americans to come here
they have to meet specific visa
requirements even though those have been
loosened it is confusing now just last
week 55 US senators co-sponsored a bill
that would lift the restrictions
altogether and that is something the
airlines would like a whole lot when the
first US commercial flight in more than
50 years touched down in Santa Clara
Cuba last August many here expected a
u.s. driven economic boom to follow and
while the number of Americans visiting
did surged seventy-four percent last
year to nearly 300,000 many expected
more how has it been so far amazing
fantastic it's been a wonderful
experience yeah Bridget Kelly from
Washington DC met her friends from LA in
Havana quick flight over from Miami
at it there would be more Americans it's
a bit of a Cuba contradiction
while hotels are so full prices have
soared north of 500 a night vendor after
vendor told us what cab driver Amedeo
Allegretti did did you expect to see
more Americans than you've seen yeah I
would expect yeah how close because it's
so easy
tonight spirit will become the third US
airline to drop service to the island
nation after frontier and silver stopped
flights amid languishing sales spirit
says there are too many factors that
prevent people from traveling easily
from the u.s. to Cuba and costs of
serving Havana continue to outweigh the
demand some analysts expect Americans
visiting Cuba to hit two million
annually by 2025 but a survey out this
month found only 2% were likely to plan
a trip in the next six months did the
gold rush not happen or just not happen
as fast as people thought I think it
didn't happen as fast as people thought
Collin Laverty organizes tours in Cuba
I think expectations need to be set
there's there's not any luxury travel in
Cuba right now the luxuries in the
people the art the music the history the
culture US carriers believe Americans
will see the appeal in time but American
Airlines cut service by 25% as it
reduced flights to several cities while
still opening a ticket office in Havana
to cater to Cubans JetBlue continues to
see potential despite dropping 300 seats
a day by plying smaller planes the
predictions say that there's going to be
tremendous growth Gisele Cortez is
jetblue's director of international
airports I can't speak for the
competitors but JetBlue remains
committed to this market for the long
haul the tourist infrastructure in Cuba
is lacking cell phone services spotty so
is Wi-Fi and most Americans can't use
their credit cards while they're here
the early winter looks to be cruise
ships because as they come into port
they bring all the infrastructure a
visitor could need
we should tell you the Trump
administration is reviewing the loosened
travel restriction so this all could
change again Nora right Kris Van Cleave
and what looks like a very sunny Havana
this morning looks great there thank you